my daughter cursed for the first time
the other day I didn't get mad we was
watching SpongeBob right something
happened to Patrick out of nowhere she
got mad she like
I said wait what what'd you say she
she's a they got Patrick dad you're
not watching
whoa all right
here's here's why I didn't get an
attitude I'll tell you why I didn't get
an attitude okay I didn't get attitude
because I remember my first time cussing
my first time cussing was because my mom
smacked me in front of company my
friends was over my house I'm downstairs
we playing we having a good time my mom
come downstairs she said hey I told you
to keep it down you don't run this house
I do okay with that being said that's it
you're done go to bed smack you set me
up to my room now you know when you get
smacked when you're a kid you get hyped
when you get by yourself
you gonna smack me
[Applause]
I was emotional I was an emotional ass
kid
I'm running away
I packed the bag and everything you know
how many times I packed the bag with a
toy
pack the bag with one toy I'm out I'm
sick of it
me and He-Man are out
my mom gay my mom gave me permission to
cuss one time
one times gave me permission to cuss I'm
in school I'm being bad my teacher got
mad I said Kevin come here somebody
comes to the front of the class wrote a
note stay with the note to my chest
so make sure your mother read the note I
get home my mom read the note the note
said maybe if you showed your son some
more attention at home he wouldn't act
like a fool in school right my mom
rather know she said let me tell you
something you tell her mind her damn
business before I come down there and I
beat her ass
I thought okay do you want me to say it
like that or do you want me to take some
stuff out what I say what I said tell
her mind her dad
I said I heard what you say I just want
to make sure that you know that you tell
me to say the same thing Kevin if I tell
you again I'ma smack the at you
nah I got it okay I got it
I got it all right
keep in mind it's a lot of pressure all
right my mom just gave me permission to
go to school to cuss my teacher out I
didn't feel comfortable with the
situation so I wanted to practice I want
to go upstairs I want to go over my
lines so
I'm in the mirror I'm going over my
lines I'm like okay all right okay all
right okay
my mom told me to tell you
to mind your damn nice too loud that's
way too loud
that's not believable it's too loud
finally I go over it I get it down I'm
like you know what I'm gonna go to bed
early get some rest because I got a big
day ahead of me tomorrow I don't I don't
really mess this up
so I go to bed I wake up get dressed put
on my pants my shirt I get on the school
bus all my friends see me they get hyped
oh canvas on the bus everybody look cab
on the bus what up Kev I was like yo not
today y'all I got a lot of stuff in my
mind
I can't really have y'all throwing me
off and my friend was like what you
talking about I can't really get into it
all I can tell y'all is that it's about
to go down
[Music]
sure she starts speaking everybody hello
good morning good morning hello hello
good morning she see me she's like Kevin
I said Miss Green
she said just let your mother read the
note I said yes I did
she said well what did your mother say I
took a deep breath I looked at my
friends I was like it's about to go back
I said well uh
my mom told me to tell you
to mind your damn business
little stupid
little dumb teacher
two plus two not knowing what the
it is
call sign crying down your back fat foot
hands long titted no nipple having
ass
the that was crazy my friends was
in the background it was like oh
[Applause]
that she ain't had no nipples
I got suspended I got suspended
and I asked her my mom beat the out
of me when I got home I told you to say
two cuss words you said 76 of them
I thought I was Samuel L Jackson I'm
taking tired of these
teachers in this school I
had a trench coat on I flapped it
like you know when you flap it you got
to get that air under it
everybody in this I don't give a
I want to tell you one story uh this
this was the best meal I've ever had in
my life all right this happened when I
was 11 years old in Chicago Illinois
where I grew up and it took place at a
little uh restaurant called the salt and
pepper Diner which was a family
restaurant in the city yes yes you know
the salt and pepper Diner it's a
wonderful family restaurant in in
Chicago which means that it caters
mainly to teenagers and homeless
schizophrenics
now I go into this place one day uh when
I'm 11 with my best friend John and I
should say that his name is also John
I'm not calling myself my own best
friend
it's a separate human being
we walk into the salt and pepper Diner
one day and they had a jukebox there all
right and the Jukebox was three plays
for a dollar
so we put in seven dollars and selected
21 plays of Tom Jones's what's new
pussycat
and then we ordered and waited foreign
here's the thing about when what's new
pussycat plays over and over and over
and over and over again
the second time it plays your immediate
thought is not hey someone's playing
what's new pussycat again it's hey
what's new pussycat is a lot longer than
I first thought
and it has like a dip in the middle you
know how some songs have a dip like like
Guns and Roses November Rain you're like
hey November rain's over no it's not
there's more
the third time it plays you're thinking
maybe someone's playing what's new
pussycat again the
the fourth what's new pussycat four
times or at least someone played it
twice and it's a really long song
so the fifth time is the kicker
now we're watching the entire Diner at
this point
most people have gotten wind as to
what's going on
and we're staring at this one guy and
he's sitting in his booth and his like
hand is shaking while his stupid kids
jump around and like he's been onto us
since the beginning when he's staring at
his coffee cup like this and he has this
look on his face like oh like he just
got his 30-day chip from anger
management
are you staring like this and the fourth
play Fades out
it's dead quiet
and then I don't know if you know this
but the song begins very subtly
what's new cat and the guy goes
God damn
hounds on the table and silverware flies
everywhere and it was fantastic
but a word about my friend John and what
a genius he was because when we were
first up at the Jukebox and we were
punching in the what's new Pussycats all
right
in about seven
and then John says to me hey hey hey
wait before we drop in another what's
New Pussycat
let's put in one it's not unusual
wait
after seven what's new Pussycats
in a row
suddenly
no no no no no no no it's not our usual
and the sigh of relief has swept through
the diner
people were ecstatic
it was like the liberation of France
you know for years scientists have
wondered can you make grown men and
women weep Tears of Joy by playing Tom
Jones's It's Not Unusual and the answer
is yes you can as long as it is preceded
by seven what's new Pussycats
and on the other hand when we went back
thank you
holy
It's Not Unusual Fades out
[Laughter]
it's dead quiet
[Music]
what's new pussycat people went
insane
no one could handle it
and they were surrounded by this like
seemingly indifferent staff you know
that was just like yep same as
always
my only wish is that one of the
schizophrenic had stood up and been like
now you know
now you know what it's like to live in
my brain
they unplugged the Jukebox after 11
plays
and that was the best meal I've ever had
you gotta make life interesting like
that because the is flimsy
life is flimsy you think you're gonna
live forever not gonna live forever
it's dangerous out here we know what's
going on
I travel now you know I used to think DC
had the roughest ghettos in the country
nah
I have seen some now
oh there's some rough rough areas
outside of DC
yeah everybody should go to the ghetto I
was taking it together one time that's
the worst when you get taken you're not
expecting to go
you know usually you want to know when
you're going together like I'm going to
see some loud I got to prepare
myself I'm gonna do something crazy
when you're taking it's different
I had a limousine driver
it was after a show it was late at night
it was like three in the morning
had limousine drive it was a nice guy
talking to me and oh hey where you
from dog
DC word
that's a rough City man
and the cell phone saw The Ring hold on
one second
hello
also what
what the stop that what the
now now
that it I'm on my way
I gotta make a stop real quick
at three o'clock in the morning I didn't
know he was taking me to ghetto at first
I started looking at the window I was
like what the is gun store gun
store liquor store Gun Store where the
are you taking me
it's gonna look good he didn't say
just pulled up in front of an old
rickety building that looked like a
project now I never been there before
I'm not sure if it was a project but it
certainly had all the familiar symptoms
of a project
a crackhead ran this way
and then another one jumped out of tree
and
[Applause]
and I said I'll be right back
and left me took the keys with me just
let me
at three o'clock in the morning in front
of a project in a limousine
this was not good
I was like man I gotta look around see
if I can see some landmarks and figure
out where I'm at
I might have to escape on foot
now this is when I knew I was in a bad
neighborhood you only see this in the
worst neighborhoods remember it's three
o'clock in the morning it's three
o'clock in the morning
I look out the window
it was a baby standing on a
corner
and the baby the baby didn't even look
scared he was just standing there
I mean it made me sad it made me say it
really good you know because I want to
help the baby
I don't trust you either I'm sorry click
the old baby on the corner trick eh
I'm not gonna fall for that
where is this limousine drive you know I
stopped feeling bad
time goes by I start feeling worse like
man what is wrong with me what the hell
is wrong I'm scared of a baby
this baby could be in trouble he might
need my help I gotta do something
but I wasn't gonna get out the car
I'm serious man I just packed the window
a little bit
there's an old limousine I can roll it
down
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
that was scary man every once in a
while like a crackhead would come up to
the car and look in the Windows like
Jurassic parking should he be looking
online
hey get out of here cracky
that baby was still standing there man
that's not feeling bad again yeah we
make you feel guilty sometimes you know
man what is wrong with me man I have
just bought weed from a from an infant
I can't condone this kind of behavior
what am I thinking I can't let the fear
ruin my morals
got to do something
hey baby
stop selling weed all right you got your
whole life ahead of you
he said you I got kids to
feed
I live in New York City and uh
it's okay there I live in a nice
building I never lived in a nice place
before when I was growing up I had no
money
um I mean my mom didn't didn't matter I
was a child but um I'm not used to it
because it's nice it's like a pretty
Courtyard with flowers and a fountain
with little marble boys pissing I don't
know
mountains
like all Fountain sculptors are
pedophiles basically you you can't get
up and made without
do you make me a fountain yes I'll get
started right away
it's finished
and it's just little boys pissing on the
face of a Greek god that looks like him
a lot
ah it's piss on me forever
anyway there's one of those in the
courtyard of my building
and uh
my first week in the building about a
year ago I went down to the Courtyard
for the first time and I didn't look too
good you know it was a Sunday morning
that's my least presentable hour
a lot of you know just stains just like
you know food and me and whatever and
someone said I'm sitting there
oh shut up
oh
anyway but so there I was
I'm sitting on the stone bench of this
Courtyard and uh feeling a little out of
place
you know there's these fancy dormant and
stuff and then there's this guy looking
at me I noticed he's looking at me from
across the courtyard
and he's all spiffy looking he's got
brown shoes and
he's looking at me like hmm I could tell
he was thinking I don't live in the
building
he thinks I just wandered in off the
streets and sat in the courtyard and I
can tell he's thinking of coming over
and dealing with me on his own
and I'm sitting there thinking like oh
please do that yes please come on come
on come on come on
and I'm trying to look even more gross
than like pulling up my shirt or
whatever and then I see him go oh no
that's not gonna do it all and he comes
over to me hmm
and I'm like um
I'm so excited
the confrontation where I'm not wrong at
all and he thinks I am
so he comes over
it says uh excuse me do you live in this
building
and I said no
Because Why not start there
he goes well then what are you doing
here
and I said I just need to rest I'm
having a hard time
he says this is private property
and I said well I don't really believe
in that you know just the worst things I
could say from his point of view is
basically all the things I was saying
and he goes well if you don't leave I'm
going to talk to the doorman I was like
can I just stay like five more hours so
he's new and he goes over to the doorman
and I see him talking about me to the
doorman like this and then I see the
doorman going oh no that guy lives here
that's okay
and the look on his face
it was just so it was this beautiful
cocktail of anger and confusion
it's like I hadn't invented a new way to
hurt somebody's feelings that's that's
how excited I was
oh no I'd be a lot better off if I would
have studied more when I was growing up
you know
but you know where it all went wrong was
the day they started the spelling bee
because up until that day I was an idiot
but nobody else knew you know
when the spelling bee day you know
popped up all right kids up against the
wall it's time for public humiliation
spell the word wrong sit down in front
of your friends
you know that's great for little egos
hey look at me I'm a I wasn't even
close
I was using numbers and stuff
that's why I admired that kid who
spelled it wrong on purpose so he could
sit down you know
he knew he wasn't going to win so why
stand there for three hours first round
cat k-a-t I'm out of here
then as he passed you I know there's two
T's
I remember my teacher asked me Brian
what's the i before e role
um
i before e
always
what are you an idiot Brian apparently
so she explains it no Brian it's i
before e except after C and when
sounding like a as a neighboring way and
on weekends and holidays and all
throughout May and you'll always be
wrong no matter what you say
it's a hard rule
that's a rough rule
plurals were hard too Brian how do you
make a word of plural
you put an ass you put an S at the end
of it when
oh
on weekends and holidays
[Applause]
oh Brian now let me show you so she
asked this kid to know everything Irwin
Irwin Irwin what is he plural for ox
auction the farmer used his oxen Brian
what
Brian what's the plural for a box
ing
I bought two boxing of donuts
no Brian no
let's try another one Irwin what is he
plural for goose geese I saw a flock
of geese
Brian what
Brown what's the plural for moose
moosen
[Music]
I saw a flock of moosen
there are many of them many much moosin
out in the woods in the wood is in the
woods in
the meat's wanting the food food is the
eating is it the meats wanted food and
wooding it is it food in the wooden
isn't Brian Brian
you're an imbecile
in the southern
and German Brian German Jermaine
Jermaine Jackson
five Tito Brown what the hell are you
talking about I don't know
I don't know really
[Music]
I think the worst day that was the day
the science project was due
waking up that morning that was fun huh
yeah
you're headed pop off your pillow oh no
let's do today
I had nine months to work on it I did
nothing
I have a cardboard box
a boxing
and you'd show up you're scared because
you don't have anything good and you
found out all the other kids their
parents made theirs for them I hated
that you know they're backing it on
flatbed trucks
one kid with a volcano he didn't have to
zip up his own pants but he built a
volcano
you had to swing that
I don't know what to do for my project
so I brought in a paper cup filled with
dirt just hoping she'd know I'm an idiot
and just walk right on past me
as long as I was holding something
what do you have there Brian
will explain it
well it's a cop with dirt in it I call
it cup of dirt
you should move on now you just go ahead
and move on head on down the line there
so she went to this one kid there was a
kid in my class he made the same solar
system like 19 years in a row you know a
bunch of styrofoam balls held together
with coat hangers hey you're breaking
some new ground there Copernicus
he's going to big yellow ones the Sun
the yellow one is the Sun
okay all right what are these other
planets the big yellow one is the sun
all right calm down all right